[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit hanna zimmermann und christian
sievers
guten abend hinein auch werden wir die
lage in der ukraine gerade wie in
echtzeit miterleben per handy videos und
augenzeugen berichten es ist wie immer
im krieg der wahre horror das ganze
ausmaß des grauens zeigt sich erst
später mit verzögerung wenn es wieder
möglich ist mit reportern und kameras an
die orte zu gehen an denen russland
soldaten man muss wohl sagen barbarisch
gewütet haben zumindest gehen aus einem
gebiet nördlich von kiew grauenhafte
bilder um die welt die allem anschein
nach auf systematische kriegsverbrechen
schließen lassen der beitrag von
annegret oster zeigt erschreckende
szenen das als hinweis für sie vorweg es
gibt keine worte die diesen bildern
gerecht werden können fahrt durch die
straßen von butscher leichen von
zivilisten am straßenrand überall mutter
einst friedliche vorstadt von kiew ist
zu einem massengrab geworden die
überlebenden leben neben den toten die
todesangst noch ins gesicht geschrieben
es war furchtbar
zweimal wäre ich fast gestorben einmal
ist eine kugel durch mein fenster und
ist in meinem kleiderschrank gelandet
das zweite mal ist ein granatsplitter
nur knapp an einem ball vorbei und
draußen hat ein mann auf mich gezielt
aber er hat vorbeigeschossen
fast einen monat lang war butter von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten fast einen monat
lang tobten die kämpfer auch viele
russen starben verbrannten in ihren
panzern
sie taten mir leid sie war noch sehr
jung 18 20 jahre alt ihr ganzes leben
hatten sie noch vor sich
jetzt räumt die ukrainische polizei auf
entschärft minen kümmert sich um gas
wasser elektrizität für die lebenden 280
tote sollen den massengräbern beigesetzt
worden sein nur wenige finden eine etwas
würdigere letzter die menschen dankbar
dass alles vorbei ist und jetzt hilfe
leisten
danke danke für alles ich verbeuge mich
ein berater von präsident zielinski
spricht von verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit und kündigte ermittlungen
an
in butter ihre bienen hoster mail zeigen
sich szenen wie aus horrorfilmen post
apokalyptische bilder
unter den opfern der russischen
verbrechen sind vergewaltigte frauen die
sie versucht haben zu verbrennen
ermordete beamte ermordete kinder
ermordete alte ermordete männer viele
von ihnen mit gefesselten händen mit
anzeichen von folter mit kugeln in ihrem
russland dementiert die bilder aus
butter sein eine weitere inszenierung
des regimes in kiew für die westlichen
medien
ihre pin liegt gleich neben butscher die
bilder ähneln sich der preis für den
erbitterten kampf gegen die russischen
invasoren der preis für die verteidigung
der hauptstadt kiew tod und zerstörung
die kleinstadt ostia netz im osten des
landes sie wurde nicht nur geschossen
sondern auch einen monat lang von den
aggressoren besetzt russen vertrieben
die einwohner aus ihren wohnungen
plünderten die supermärkte vorgestern
sind sie abgezogen doch frieden wird
hier noch lange nicht herrschen
christoph reuter kollege vom spiegel war
der erste internationale journalisten in
dem kurort trotz der 20.000 einwohner
nachdem die russischen soldaten von dort
abrückten hertha guten abend
bemerkt wie haben denn die menschen dort
das erlebt sie berichten dass die
erstmal wie fremde durch ihre eigene
stadt gewandert sind
ja das irre war ihr singt ja erst
ungefähr 36 stunden nach dem abzug der
russen in die stadt gekommen nur da die
bevölkerung kein mobilfunknetz mehr
hatte keine land lions erkennen ein
festnetztelefon sich überhaupt nicht
mehr auf die straße traute weil leute
willkürlich erschossen worden waren
wussten die zum teil nicht was geschieht
hundert meter weiter und haben trotz der
totenstille im ort über einen ganzen tag
lang sich nicht aus ihren häusern raus
getraut erst als die ersten ukrainischen
verbände einrücken kam sie raus und als
wir dann kam haben wir diese szenen
erlebt wo menschen auf der straße
langlaufen jemanden sehen den sie kennen
anfangen zu weinen und sie in die arme
fallen du lebst und das waren nachbarn
die vielleicht oder leute die 23 500
meter voneinander entfernt gewohnt haben
aber niemand wusste was ist mit den
anderen was es den geschehen leben die
noch
unglaubliche und vorstellbare szenen
jetzt haben die russen ja in den aller
ersten kriegstagen den ort trotz der
netz bereits eingenommen und besetzt ich
habe schon gesagt ein kurort
tschaikowsky hat dort mal komponiert war
denn das so geplant war da in
irgendeiner form eine strategie
erkennbar nein also zum einen nicht weil
wir völlig sinnlos mit 600 und mehr
soldaten in einen strategisch
unbedeutenden kurort in 30 kilometer
entfernung von der grenze einzurollen
und der hauptgrund dass sie das getan
habe war das eine brücke nördlich von
afrika wo man weitergefahren wäre
richtung hier in die zentrale ukraine
die wachen ukraine gesprengt worden und
dann ist dieser konvoi am 24 februar am
ersten tag des krieges wieder machen
nach rechts abgebogen und dann kam
offensichtlich der befehl ihr bleibt
jetzt hier in trossingen netz und wartet
weitere befehle ab so sind die da
eingeholt und die wenigen ukraine die
mit denen geredet haben die mit ihnen zu
tun haben die wurden dann von den russen
gefragt nach zwei drei wochen sagen
haben wir das schon erobert lebt sie
lenski noch und dann merken die ukraine
den russen wissen selber überhaupt nicht
was im ganzen land passiert und sie
hatten auch zumindest konnten sie nichts
sagen dazu sie hatten überhaupt keinen
plan wohin geht es als nächstes was
wollen wir von diesem ort
wie lange bleiben wie hier das einzige
was die geantwortet haben wenn sie
überhaupt was sagt
jetzt habe heute heute diese
grauenvollen bilder aus butter gesehen
kleinen ort nördlich von kiew wie hat
man sich denn die russische
besatzungszeit in dem ort in dem sie
waren vorzustellen
das spannende ist dadurch dass die
russen doch so schröer eingegangen sind
und einen ganzen monat daran kann man
dort sehr gut die
kurve nachvollziehen von soldaten die
kommen an diesen ort der nicht teil
ihres planes war wenn es überhaupt hier
einen gab die lassen sich erstmal im
polizeihauptquartier im bahnhof nieder
haben mit der lokalen bevölkerung nichts
zu tun dann gehen ihnen die vorgänger
auf dann gehen ihnen die schmerzmittel
aus dann werden sie nach einer weile von
der ukrainischen armee angegriffen die
zum teil auch durch die bevölkerung die
genauen positionen
ihrer panzer stellung übermittelt
bekommen fünf meter rechts von vassilis
bäckerei und so weiter das heißt die
soldaten geraten unter druck plündern
die häuser plündern die legen plündern
das krankenhaus und haben das gefühl
jeder in diesem ort ist gegen sie was ja
auch stimmt und rächen sich an der
zivilbevölkerung und es gibt
offensichtlich nichts keine befehle von
oben
aber auch nichts was sie persönlich
zurückgehalten hat
wahllos menschen zu erschießen zu
foltern in ihrem verhör keller
umzubringen und in etwas kleineren
maßstab wir haben auch leichen gesehen
aber nicht so viele wie in botschaft in
etwas kleineren maßstab das zu tun was
sie auch fuchs beste weise in butter
getan
jetzt ist die stadt wieder in der hand
der ukraine kann denn der ort jetzt
aufatmen
also der ort ist in eine ist eine leicht
surreal situation der ist 30 kilometer
von der russischen grenze entfernt
denn die russische armee will dann kann
sie selbst mit weitreichender arten wie
diesen auf weiter geschossen und senkt
die russen wollen könnten sie dort
innerhalb von einer stunde mit
gepanzerten fahrzeugen wieder sein aber
das was die leute trotzdem aufatmen
lässt ist der eindruck den sie in trotz
der netz haben aber auch in vielen
gegenden rund um hartz iv wir waren wo
die russen ebenfalls sich zurückgezogen
haben dass alle sagen die sind so
abgekämpft die haben so viel an material
und auch an soldaten verloren das im
moment hier in dieser gegend im osten
der ukraine
die angst ein bisschen gerichten ist
dass sie so schnell nicht wiederkommen
christoph reuter kollege vom spiegel
herzlichen dank für ihre schilderung
die apokalyptischen szenen aus der
ukraine sind heute auch in den
regierungszentralen des westens gesehen
worden auch dort steigt der druck mehr
druck zu machen auf wladimir putin die
eu will neue sanktionen beschließen der
bundeskanzler verlangt zitat olaf scholz
diese verbrechen des russischen militärs
müssen wir schonungslos aufklären
thomas reichert hat mir dazu ein paar
stunden bevor olaf scholz abend im
kanzleramt vor die kameras tritt hat er
bereits eine pressemitteilung zu
veröffentlichen lassen darin fordert er
die täter und ihre auftraggeber zur
rechenschaft zu ziehen aber zunächst von
ihm kein wort zu weiteren sanktionen
und jetzt wir werden im kreis der
verbündeten in den nächsten tagen
weitere maßnahmen beschließen präsident
putin und seine unterstützer werden die
folgen spüren und wir werden der ukraine
weiterhin waffen zur verfügung stellen
damit sie sich gegen die russische
invasion verteidigen kann was aber meint
scholz mit weiteren maßnahmen das lässt
er offen
auch außenministerin baerbock denn die
bilder aus butter unerträglich und
kündigt per twitter an wir werden die
sanktionen gegen russland verschärfen in
berlin direkt wird der vizekanzler
konkreter kündigte sanktionen gegen
weitere personen an noch mehr
einschnitte beim handel mit technischen
gütern und dem finanzmarkt aber habe
kein sofortiges energie embargo
wir arbeiten jeden tag daran jeden tag
ein stück weit unabhängig zu werden von
gas und von öl und wir haben 14 15 20
jahre lang hat deutschland sich abhängig
gemacht von russland innerhalb von vier
wochen drehen wir das jetzt um habeck
deutet an dass die bundesregierung gegen
die deutschland tochter der russischen
konzern rosneft und gazprom vorgehen
könnte derweil wächst die kritik in
berlin an den energie milliarden für
putin selbst bei der linken die ihn
lange verteidigte es ist natürlich ein
wahnsinn dass auf der einen seite wir
mit jeder lieferung von gas aber auch
von öl und kohle letztlich den krieg
putins mitfinanzieren das ein
furchtbares dilemma es muss eine antwort
geben es muss eine reaktion geben solche
verbrechen dürfen nicht unbeantwortet
bleiben das muss auch putin klar also
stoppte gas und deswegen muss jetzt im
kreise der eu-minister genau das
miteinander besprochen und das war
bisher unsere stärke die bundesregierung
sagt sie tue alles um schnell
loszukommen von russlands energie
lieferungen für die ukraine das zeigen
die bilder aus butscher geht das nicht
schnell genug
wir gehen jetzt läuft nach kiew zu
unserer reporterin dort katrin eigendorf
kathrin guten namens in kiew hat die
russische armee ihre truppen
zurückgezogen du bist heute im zug
dorthin gefahren zusammen mit menschen
die auch wieder zurückkehren in ihrer
heimat mit welchen gefühlen tun sie das
ja was interessant war der zug war fast
ausgebucht und wir haben dort die
gelegenheit gehabt mit vielen menschen
zu sprechen die wirklich alle mit großen
schmerzen und großer trauer zurückkehren
und großer angst auch wie sie uns
erzählen dass sie gar nicht wissen was
sie dort erwartet dass sie angst davor
haben wie sie ihr leben weiterführen
können die
grauenvollen bilder die wir gesehen
haben ausputzer darüber reden die
menschen natürlich auch die jetzt
zurückkehren und sie fürchten dass sie
in ein land in einem kompletten
ausnahmezustand jetzt dass sie dort
irgendwie wieder fuß fassen müssen denn
sie sagen wir können ja nicht dauerhaft
im ausland bleiben aber diese gräuel zu
dokumentieren das ist natürlich den
menschen jetzt unglaublich wichtig und
ja ich kann nur sagen ich habe so viele
menschen im zug erlebt die wirklich
tränen in den augen hatten sogar geweint
haben die sagen wir sind völlig
verzweifelt wir wissen eigentlich gar
nicht wie unser leben hier weiter gehen
soll und warum fahren sie dann trotzdem
was erwarten sie es ihnen das geld knapp
geworden oder was sind die gründe
das sind sehr unterschiedliche gründe
also einige haben uns gesagt dass ihnen
das geld knapp geworden ist dass sie auf
dauer nicht im ausland leben können aber
eine frau hat uns zum beispiel auch
gesagt wir die meisten von uns sind hier
am 24
februar hier ganz plötzlich aufgebrochen
haben alles stehen und liegen lassen wir
müssen irgendwann zurückkehren weil die
menschen haben ja auch gar keine
gelegenheit gehabt irgendetwas
mitzunehmen und sie sehen jetzt eine
chance das ist jetzt der erste moment wo
sie wieder in ihr land in ihre stadt
zurückkehren können aber die realitäten
hier sind natürlich grauenvoll und ich
denke das größte bestreben der
ukrainischen regierung ist jetzt das zu
dokumentieren dass der welt
vorzuführen und genau zu zeigen was hier
passiert ist deswegen lädt man jetzt
auch journalisten und auch wir werden
dabei sein zu einer
dazu ein diese gebiete anzugucken das
ist nicht so einfach möglich weil die
größtenteils auch noch vermin sind aber
auch wir werden gelegenheit haben uns in
butscher um zu gucken und dort zu drehen
diese bilder werden uns weiter
beschäftigen hatte den film moment
herzlichen dank
europa guckt heute gespannte und
durchaus auch angespannt richtung ungarn
da entscheidet sich nämlich gerade wer
das land künftig regiert viktor orban
will eine fünfte amtszeit die vierte in
folge es entscheidet sich auch ob der
zunehmend autoritären regierungsstil in
budapest weitergeht den ihm die eu
vorwirft die meisten medien unter
staatlicher kontrolle die nähe zum
herren im kreml die auch durch den krieg
kaum beeinträchtigt wirkt da steht also
einiges auf dem spiel für ein eu land
sehr ungewöhnlich sind mehr als 200
internationale beobachter vor ort sie
sollen sicherstellen dass die wahl
korrekt verläuft der aktuelle stand
jetzt von wolf christian ulrich
ernüchterung und sorge bei anhängern der
opposition angesichts erster prognosen
ein neuer sieg orban scheint sich
abzuzeichnen
das wäre ein traum dann werden viele
junge leute weggehen
ministerpräsident viktor orban gab sich
schon am morgen siegesgewiss
einen großen sieg das ist was dieses
land braucht
im system orban ist alles auf diesen
grossen sieg ausgerichtet presse
wirtschaft machtapparat doch dann wurde
russlands krieg für putin partner orban
im wahlkampf zum problem urban zögerte
zunächst bei sanktionen und die
nato-partner mussten ihn die aufstockung
von nato-truppen in ungarn förmlich
aufdrängen
außenministers jato träger des
russischen freundschaftsorden lehnt
waffenlieferungen für die ukraine bis
heute ab
konkret bringt immer risiko und gefahr
das ist in unserer nachbarschaft das ist
gefährlich wir müssen daraus bleiben
orban laviert zwischen ost und west
seine wähler goutieren das
ich bin zwar nicht komplett zufrieden
mit der regierung aber ich finde dass in
der aktuellen situation japans fidesz
partei besser ist
angesichts der grauenerregenden
kriegsverbrechen in butter in der
ukraine die weltweit für entsetzen
sorgen deutet organs kabinettschef am
wahlabend an härtere sanktionen gegen
russland nicht abzulehnen
wir wollen es vermeiden um allein zu
bleiben aber
vernünftiger sanktionen gemeinsam holen
der spitzenkandidat der ungarischen
opposition hatte orban putin problem zum
wahlkampfthema gemacht
wir sind pro eu und pro nato wir glauben
fest dass ungarns sicherheit von unserer
nato mitgliedschaft im abhängt das
können wir nicht verraten wie aber an
dass
die opposition hatte es im wahlkampf
schwer für ihre überzeugungen zu werben
denn um seine macht dauerhaft zu sichern
hatte orban das wahlgesetz geändert das
führte dazu dass er vor vier jahren mit
49 prozent der stimmen ganze zwei
drittel der sitze im ungarischen
parlament errang die sechs wichtigsten
oppositionsparteien traten deshalb
gemeinsam an um überhaupt eine chance zu
haben
spitzenkandidat peter marke sei ein
konservativer wirtschaftswissenschaftler
kämpft gegen die korruption des orban
systems außerdem ist die opposition klar
proben
ich möchte einen ungarn wo die jungen
leute auch bleiben können arbeit finden
und zumindest annähernd gehälter auf
westlichem niveau bekommen
markise gab heute morgen in seinem
südungarischen heimatort die stimme ab
wir kämpfen für demokratie und anstand
für die unabhängigkeit der justiz und
für rechtstaatlichkeit in ungarn
die wähler scheinen anders entschieden
zu haben sie werden wohl mit orban an
den mann der sagt ungarn fest und meint
urban fest
und noch eine wahl heute auf die wir
schauen sollten und das macht jetzt ganz
genau denn auch in serbien wurde heute
ein neues parlament gewählt und außerdem
fanden präsidentschaftswahlen statt
dabei wird die wiederwahl des
amtierenden staatschefs alexander busch
erwartet auch seine rechtskonservative
fortschrittspartei dürfte den umfragen
zufolge ihre mehrheit im parlament
verteidigen coach möchte serbien die eu
führen war aber bisher auch um gute
beziehungen zu russland bemüht
die bundesregierung hat sich darauf
geeinigt dass mieter die klimaabgabe bei
den heizkosten in den meisten fällen
nicht mehr alleine zahlen müssen künftig
soll auch der vermieter einen teil
übernehmen allerdings abhängig von der
energiebilanz des hauses ab 2023 soll
ein stufenplan gelten ist ein haus
schlecht saniert und gedämmt zahlt der
vermieter einen großteil der co2 abgabe
beim hohen energiestandard e h 55 zeit
er dagegen nichts
bei schweren unwettern im
brasilianischen bundesstaat rio de
janeiro sind mindestens 16 menschen ums
leben gekommen
nach starkregen kam es zu erdrutschen in
der küstenregion ganze häuser wurden von
den schlamm und erdmassen decke rissen
und bewohner verschüttet erst mitte
februar hatten heftige regenfälle
nördlich von rio zu erdrutschen und
überschwemmungen geführt dabei starben
mindestens
234 personen
papst franziskus hat am zweiten tag
seiner weiterreise zu gebeten für die
ukraine aufgerufen bei einer messe vor
tausenden gläubigen in floriana
bezeichnete franziskus den krieg als
sakrileg zum abschluss seiner reise
besuchte er ein aufnahmezentrum für
geflüchtete dort warnte er vor einem
zitat schiffbruch der zivilisation
und dann ist heute ein tag der
eigentlich ein ausrufezeichen bekommen
sollte der tag an dem die allermeisten
corona beschränkungen in den
allermeisten teilen von deutschland
wegfallen ersatzlos es ist ein tag mit
fragezeichen geworden denn die
infektionszahlen sind weiter hoch und
die einen fühlen sich jetzt dem hilflos
dem virus hilfloser ausgesetzt die
anderen freuen sich auf die neue alte
zeit am ende steht eine erkenntnis die
diese phase der pandemie beschreiben
dürfte es kommt jetzt die zeit in der
jede und jeder das risiko selbst
einschätzen muss mehr freiheit für alle
aber auch mehr verantwortung
eva schiller
die einen atmen auf andere gehen auf
nummer sicher bremen am nachmittag für
die fußball fans beginnt das prinzip
eigenverantwortung wenn die straßenbahn
türen aufgehen dann endet die masken
pflicht abziehen oder auf lassen
das muss jetzt jeder selber wissen zum
teil ja die instanzen sind hoch aber wir
müssen auch mal mit lärm mit dem virus
um umzugehen wenn man jetzt so viele
leute um sich rum 2
ja diese bilder sind von heute tausende
strömen ins ausverkaufte weser stadion
trotz inzidenz von 1800 gilt auch im
stadion keine masken pflicht mehr
verkaufsoffener sonntag im bayerischen
rosenheim einkaufen ist in fast allen
bundesländern wieder ohne maske möglich
ich denke dass so etwas eben selber
überlassen werden also ich habe mit den
models mir wäre es lieber gewesen wenn
man in den geschäften einzelhandel
supermärkten ist nach wie vor trägt
und
das ist auch für jeden praktikabel
rekord incidents prallt auf zurück
gewonnene freiheit in freude mischt sich
sorge bleibt die frage wie gut das
prinzip eigenverantwortung in der praxis
funktioniert stuttgart raichberg
realschule
die schulleiterin zählt die vielen
positiven corona fälle und findet das
ende der masken pflicht riskant vorerst
werden wir mit den klassen reden und
sagen freiwillig dürfte die maske tragen
bitte tut das auch wenn natürlich einer
sagt nee ich hab es jetzt endlich seite
und wird die maske fallen lassen dann
können wir nichts machen der bund hat
das maßnahmen ende beschlossen land und
lehrer empfehlen masken weiter zu tragen
entscheiden werden sie das votum der
zehntklässler
wirklich muss mich auch die ganze testen
und deswegen finde ich das mit den
massen er so unnötige nicht die maske
absetzen für jeden der ein problem damit
hat soll sie weiter tragen wir haben
schon sehr hohe zahlen und ohne maske es
ist halt noch schlimmer und so spiegeln
sich im klassenzimmer schon mal
aufziehen der konflikte politisches
hickhack und komplizierte corona
regelwerke vorerst passé jetzt muss sich
das prinzip eigenverantwortung
beweisen
eine aufgewühlte welt an diesem ersten
sonntag im april sank die tropeninsel
bekannt bei urlaubern für ihre
umwerfende natur und für begeisternde
menschen ist den aufruhr x 10 x 16
stunden am tag ist gerade der strom
abgestellt brütende hitze und an den
tankstellen lange warteschlangen der
frust über eine beispiellose
wirtschaftskrise entlädt sich in gewalt
es gelang cast präsident wegen einer
besorgniserregenden menschenrechtslage
bereits international in der kritik hat
jetzt den notstand ausgerufen normen
odenthal
ein staat und seine bürger geraten
aneinander
es brodelt gewaltig an diesem tag
demonstrationen tränengas wasserwerfer
dabei hatte die regierung eine
ausgangssperre verhängt das volk sollte
ruhe geben ruhe die der präsident gern
persönlich vermitteln würde
man sei in guten gesprächen sagt er mit
dem währungsfonds den gläubigern um die
finanzkrise zu entschärfen die schulden
zu drücken bis dahin müssten die bürger
einschnitte bei benzin und energieertrag
keine botschaften die die stimmung
beruhigen das vertrauen ist weg die
verzweiflung da die krise des staates
stürzt die menschen in die note
was ist das für ein leben das geht ja um
unsere grundbedürfnisse wie energie
jeden tag schalten sie jetzt für 16
stunden den strom
es gibt kein gas kein benzin wir haben
nichts zu essen keine medizin was sollen
wir denn tun sollen wir uns alle ins
meer stürzen
aus sorge wird angst aus angst wird
proteste vor dem präsidentenpalast der
vorläufige höhepunkt der sich
zuspitzenden staatskrise wie konnte es
soweit kommen an dem ausbleiben der
tourismus das hat die wirtschaft
getroffen aber sri lankas probleme
liegen tiefer es ist eine krise mit
ansage
regierung hat lange zeit das ganze geld
in ungarn euro projekt oder steckt wir
haben straßen gebaut auf denen keiner
fährt werden flughäfen gebaut wo keine
flugzeuge landen geisterstädte wo keiner
wohnt autobahnen auf denen u 11 10 oder
so laufen
es ist eine bizarre liste von teuren
mega projekten allesamt in den sand
gesetzt korruption geltungssucht
misswirtschaft wie aus dem bilderbuch
mit ausländischen krediten finanziert
die jetzt nicht mehr bedient werden
können
unsere kreditwürdigkeit wurde komplett
herunter gespielt wir sind auf ramsch
niveau kann man sagen keiner
leitungswasser und deshalb haben wir
angefangen geld zu drucken das war unser
schlimmster fehler der alles zum kippen
gebracht hat
inflation lebensmittelpreise etwa sind
im märz um 30 prozent gestiegen importe
aus dem ausland sind nicht mehr zu haben
das wenige was es gibt wird teurer und
teurer
überall nur schlangen jetzt stehe ich in
der diesel schlange heute morgen stand
ich in der milch- pulver schlauer
wenn ich morgens aufwache kostet alles
das doppelte mit meinem lohn kann ich
also nur noch halb so viel kaufen ich
verdiene so viel wie früher aber es
reicht nicht mehr bei diesen preisen
die prognosen sind düster für die bürger
und den start sri lanka droht die
zahlungsunfähigkeit und noch unruhigere
zeiten
an sri lankas schulen wurden zuletzt die
prüfungen verschoben die bögen mit den
fragen konnten nicht gedruckt werden
weil es auch am papier fehlt ein
politologe aus sri lanka sagte der faz
wir haben den bürgerkrieg bewältigt
einen verheerenden tsunami terror und
die pandemie wir haben uns immer wieder
auf aber dafür brauchen wir eine fähige
politische führung
und jetzt in der sendung noch mal hanna
und zwar mit fußball in der ersten
bundesliga gab es heute nämlich zwei
begegnungen mit folgenden ergebnissen
der fc augsburg holte sich drei punkte
mit einem 3 zu 0 gegen den vfl wolfsburg
borussia mönchengladbach und der erste
fsv mainz 05 trennten sich 1 zu 1
unentschieden und jetzt noch die
wetteraussichten morgen im norden
kräftiger regen im osten und im bergland
teils mit schnee vermischt dazu starker
südwestwind mit schweren sturmböen im
süden trocken und sonnige abschnitte 4
bis 10 grad auch in den nächsten tagen
sehr wechselhaft mit viel regen bei
teils stürmischem wind dienstag 6 bis 11
grad danach allmählich wieder milder
ja windige aussichten beim wetter die
aussichten für die welt der nachrichten
hat jetzt erik allen sehr der heute
journal ausblick
[Musik]
am montag will der weltklimarat ips sie
den letzten teil seines neuen
sachstandsberichts veröffentlichen diese
dritte abschnitt bewertet geeignete
politische und technologische maßnahmen
zur begrenzung des klimawandels zum
beispiel die entnahme von co2 aus der
atmosphäre oder was es bringt wenn die
industrialisierte welt ihren lebensstil
ändern etwa bei ernährung oder mobilität
kommt die allgemeine impfpflicht darüber
soll am donnerstag der bundestag
endgültig entscheiden mehrere vorschläge
stehen zur debatte für wen sie gelten
soll ab welchem alter und wie man sie
umsetzt auch eine verschiebung der
abstimmung auf einen späteren zeitpunkt
ist möglich sollte der vorschlag der
union dazu die mehrheit bekommen
das rennen um den élysée-palast wird am
kommenden sonntag eröffnet mit der
ersten runde der präsidentschaftswahl
auf platz 3 sie in umfragen derzeit john
cena schon einen kandidaten der linken
auf zwei die rechtspopulistin marine le
pen die dann voraussichtlich gegen zehn
aarauer antreten wird bei der stichwahl
am 24 april
wir werden darüber berichten auch
nächste woche wieder auch morgen wieder
und die nächsten nachrichten gibt es
hier gegen 0.30 heute express mit
christopher wehrmann vom gesamten
heute-journal thiemann sie einen
angenehmen sonntagabend
[Musik]